il est 6 heures du matin une brume
ceinture le mont saint michel
topshop à ses pieds comme chaque matin
400 moutons sont en route pour paître
dans ses pâturages
bien avant que les touristes arrivent le
berger yannick frein accompagne ses
moutons chaque jour depuis qu'il est
enfant
[Musique]
allez ma mère
allait
donc quitté mon bureau au quotidien
voilà
le pré salé
le prés salés un pâturage rares en
france car grâce aux embruns quotidien
son herbe est imprégné du sel de la mer
yannick est propriétaire de la moitié de
ses terres 1300 hectares de ce pré salé
couverts d'herbe qu'il appelle la plante
la particularité de cette plante ce sont
des plantes halophiles plantes qui
supportent l'eau de mer quand la marée
se retire les sels minéraux de l'yonne
se dépose sur la plante est donc à
l'ingestion de mes moutons ça va
donner une saveur à la viande qui sera
inégalable
sa viande tendre et prisé dans le monde
entier pour son goût salé sa cuisson
caramélisées et sa couleur rose et les
plus grands chefs étoilés la met alors
qu'arte une renommée qui dure depuis
cinq générations dans la famille de
yannick mon arrière grand père avait 50
mouton mort en père avait 150 moutons
mon père 400 et puis moi et puis moi 800
et puis alexandre avec alexandre ans né
à 1000 donc voilà où s'arrêteront nous
voici alexandre son fils ce matin il est
resté à la bergerie avec une partie du
troupeau car cette saison est celle de
la tonte il n'a que trois jours pour
tondre les 1000 brebis et béliers de
l'élevage familial leur laine est très
prisé en chine pour fabriquer des
matelas
le travail des tombeurs et minutieux ils
doivent rester au ras de la peau des
moutons avec leur tondeuse télescopique
pour ne pas blesser les animaux ou en 2
minutes
25 à 30 à l'heure ce travail est délicat
mais il doit être rapide car il faut
tondre 340 moutons par jour pour tenir
les délais de livraison pour un chine en
plus une jeune tondeuse des buts adele
fait partie des trente femmes tondeuse
en france
ici c'est la première fois que j'en vois
une fille tombe très courageux de sa
part et pour avoir une sacrée force dans
les bras et
le structurent mon chapeau tout le monde
s'agite dans la bergerie les à la
fiancée d'alexandre tu as cette laine
dont raffolent les chinois
tan chauffe
une laine qui est un peu sableuses et un
peu un peu jaune c'est ce qui nous a
fait réaliser un petit peu fois
donc l'accès aux pièces le bluff hervé
haut on va le sortir et on va l'enlever
chaque belle eau contient l'équivalent
de 40 brebis au total 2 tonnes de laine
seront ramassées dans 25 ballots
de retour du pâturage yannick peu c'est
la touche finale de la tonte le marquage
du troupeau pour retrouver les brebis
égarées
mon arrière grand père avec comme marque
a à f bleu il était resté une tradition
tradition ancestrale donc f cofra voilà
et donc tous les moutons sont marqués à
kf2 f pour les béliers un cef pour les
brebis
[Applaudissements]
ouais